what's going on - nothing's working not
even close it's happening isn't it
get my consciousness inside the boat
what do you special delivery wow you're
super pregnant looks like you do about
21 days from tonight I'd say someone who
understands that time is precious and
right now is all we've got
totally speaking everybody is Charlie we
got to break down this flash finale
footage there's a new round of that
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so let's just go
through the footage as we see this now
she's not anywhere in the trailer here
obviously she has something to do with
Barry defeating the thinker because the
Speed Force symbols that he was writing
when he came out of the Speed Force are
the same symbols that she was writing in
that little book the little book belongs
to DeVoe he was writing the symbols on
his blackboard right after he became -
thinker so all three of these characters
are connected through the Speed Force
symbols coffee girl is connected now in
addition to ways because the same
symbols that Barry was writing but also
she possesses the physical journal that
belonged to devote that Marlies was
thumbing through a couple episodes ago
so that will be key to whatever Barry
does inside this mine space in rescuing
everyone and saving the world there's
not a whole lot of season 5 teaser stuff
in this trailer but they always tease
what's happening at the beginning of
season 5 in the finale so just be aware
of that we've talked about who the
villain might be I've seen a lot of new
theories too so I'll address that when I
post my finale video but there'll be
some more DC posting later this week so
maybe I'll do another video for that but
obviously we get that very comic book II
moment that we've been waiting for since
they announced that the thinker was
going to be a comic book villain on the
flash TV show so if you're not a big
comic book reader in the comics when the
flash the Wally West flash fought Geoff
Johns version of the thinker there was
this famous panel with all these wires
sticking in his head so within the issue
which is actually titled crossfire part
3 the thinking man so it's part of this
larger thinker arc Wally West learns
that the only way that he can beat the
thinker is by giving himself over to him
so he's kind of more of a tech based
villain and he's
looking for more processing power so
he's sort of absorbing the city he's
making it part of himself so the flash
literally has the fastest mind alive
which makes it the fastest computer
alive on the planet that's why the
thinker wanted him so Wally West gives
himself over so the thinker sticks all
of his tendrils in his head and briefly
until the flash can fight him within his
mind space like something out of
Inception or going back even further the
matrix I've been using The Matrix is a
more apt description if you want to read
that volume
it's flash vol 2 number 186 but it's
part of the larger crossfire arc so I
would recommend you read that it has a
me net black a lot of the stuff that
they adapted for this season but
obviously they changed a lot of it for
the TV show so you can see why they
probably did things this way instead of
having the thinker just like put his
hand with the tendril in it on top of
Barry's head and take him into his mind
that way they want the Flash's
personality within Devoe's mind to be
free of DeVoe and when he takes somebody
like when he took Ralph they become part
of him so it's a little bit different
there's not like somebody running around
inside your mind but when they were
filming this episode a couple weeks ago
people were like how come we're seeing
the pudgy version of Ralph on the set
the one from before he became a hero and
got his powers near the bus so the whole
idea is is that Barrie probably
encounters some of the bus metas as he
runs through teuvos mind Ralph's being
one of them I don't know if he's gonna
rescue all the bus metas wise inside his
mind here but the producers teased a
very inception he finale this is where
they get to inception him actually going
inside his mind now I figured they would
do this when they announced the thinker
as a villain because it's one of the
most iconic geoff johns wally west comic
book panels the flash doing the thinking
man with all those wires sticking out of
his head but they've changed so much
about the comic book storyline that you
just don't know until you actually see
it so when wally west flash fought the
thinker inside his mind space it was a
very similar situation where wally went
full matrix and realized that there were
no limitations he could manifest
anything that he wanted to so because it
was the wally west version of the flash
he cloned a bunch of different versions
of him from different eras in the comics
so all these different versions of the
flash you see fighting the thinker here
these are just different versions of
wally west from different eras so you
have the really young
kid flash wally west in the yellow
costume you have him in the even earlier
red costume before he got the yellow
costume so you just get the idea there
inside a matrix like mine space there
are no limitations
you can manifest anything that your mind
can come up with so I'll be interested
to see what he manifests to try and help
him fight to vote inside the mine space
obviously the other big storyline while
Barry's inside the thinker's mine space
is all this chaos with the Enlightenment
happening in the real world you see the
skies are completely purple with like
this really twisted aurora borealis like
it's gonna be raining down Dark Matter
on everyone really soon
Joe makes a brief reference to just
everything going crazy
you see Cisco outside there fires being
lit people just going completely nuts I
love the fact that they are in jitters
at the beginning of this trailer because
we've all been talking about coffee girl
and then his seal is getting ready to
give birth she has that little device on
her forehead to prevent her from
entering other people's minds that was
the old-school inhibitor you see the
real-life version of devote walked past
her looking at her as she's getting
ready to give birth so it's like what
does he want with Cecile or is he just
coming for everyone because it sounds
like this is all happening at STAR Labs
like they brought Cecile there instead
of taking her to a traditional hospital
but they don't really give a whole lot
else away besides Barry just trying to
get used to what the mine space is like
like it looks like he's getting his ass
kicked but this is probably right after
he enters and he's not sure what's going
on I really love the way that he wakes
up inside teuvos mine space at the scene
of the crime so to speak the scene where
he exited the Speed Force and created
all the bus metas in the way he sits up
in frame is like the way he sat up at
the beginning of this season in the
beginning of the pilot when he had been
in a coma for a couple months
hey Barry it's me so obviously we have
to talk about the idea that the title is
we are the flash and that's been a bit
of a meme across the season it started
way back I think in like the second
episode or something like that what iris
said it the first time they brought it
back around a couple more times Barry
said it once when they were just working
on a normal problem then now it sounds
like they'll finally pay it off with
Barry becoming part of the thinker we
are the flesh so briefly I think what
will happen is is that the thinker will
take over Barry while he's inside the
mind space before Barry takes back over
him remember the end of the Matrix
Revolutions where he enters or allows
Smith to absorb him then destroys Smith
from the inside out
[Music]
but it'll be really interesting to see
how he tries to save the other bus
medicine that's like the other little
hanging plot thread does everybody die
because I think the idea is that they
bring ralph back at least so i don't
know if that means that they can also
bring the other ones back too we can
talk about that when the episode
actually happens because when he jumps
into a new body he effectively takes
everything with him so the old body is
just a husk and what have they been
doing with the old bodies did they put
them on ice did they bury them because
it's been a couple months since he
started jumping into other people's
bodies going all the way back to the
midseason finale so they either got a
whole bunch of popsicles in the fridge
or it's gonna be some other really
twisty explanation for how ralph can
come back out of DeVoe and still have a
body leave all your bonus video requests
in the comments below and what will
happen later today is as Marvel just
confirmed that they were gonna be doing
in eternals franchise during phase four
now they said franchise which means like
a new trilogy so it sounds like a pretty
big thing I'll do a video for that
there'll be more Deadpool to posting
really soon so be sure to go see the
movie - congratulations to the giveaway
winner from my last big video elliott
guadarrama please private message me so
I can get your contact details I'll name
a new winner when I post new DC click
here for my flash video from last night
and click here for my non-spoilery
Deadpool 2 review thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight